[Music]
maybe people have issues keeping their
cars clean it's a chore that you prefer
to put off for as long as possible well
we're here to save your day with some
quick and easy car cleaning tricks if
your car dealers knew we were telling
you about this they probably wouldn't be
too happy we've got some pretty bizarre
cleaning methods that you've likely
never heard anywhere else stay tuned
until the end to see just what you can
do with some homemade goo if this is
your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you the 20 cleaning tricks
car dealers don't want you to know 20
tennis-ball as a parking aide do you
have trouble parking in your garage it
can be hard to determine how far you are
from the garage wall the last thing you
want to do is to dent or scratch your
car as a result of poor parking skills
the easier and Vess fix for this is the
hang a tennis ball from the ceiling of
your garage for this DIY all you need is
a string or a cord a tennis ball a drill
and cup hooks drill a hole in your
tennis ball and not the string or cord
make an X on the ceiling where you're
going to screw in your cup hooks screw
in the cup and tie the string to the cup
hook and that's it 19 cleaning
headlights with toothpaste toothpaste
isn't just for cleaning your teeth
anymore apparently toothpaste does more
than make your pearly whites Sparkle the
cleaning properties in toothpastes can
also help clean your dirty foggy
headlights having dirty headlights is
quite noticeable in cars and can make
your car look older and much dirtier
than it is using this trick can also
make an older car look like new grab any
tube of toothpaste and layer it on your
headlights leave it on for a few minutes
before washing it off hopefully your
headlights will look good as new all
thanks to that $4 tube of toothpaste
this trick is great because it's so
simple and cheap 18 clean dashboard with
a toothbrush toothpaste isn't the only
thing related to dental hygiene that can
help keep your car clean toothbrushes
are a great car cleaning tool there are
many areas of a car's interior that are
hard to reach or clean with a cloth the
small bristles and head on the
toothbrush
you to get into all those nooks and
crannies this is particularly helpful
with your dashboard car dashboards
typically have knobs and buttons and
dials that are small and hard to get at
well get your car cleaner and a
toothbrush and scrub away at those areas
the toothbrush isn't only helpful with
the dashboard either but all the
textured material that you find on the
steering wheel or arm rests 17 remove
crumbs from upholstery with toothbrush
you definitely notice how easy it is to
get crumbs dirt and dust stuck to your
car's upholstery even if you try your
best to keep your car clean of junk this
is hard to avoid our rag doesn't do the
job of getting what stuck in the cracks
so this hack is a really good one to
keep in mind the secret to this dilemma
is the trusty toothbrush who knew a
toothbrush had so many uses a tooth
brushes bristles will get those fine
pesky particles out of your upholstery
in no time just make sure to vacuum up
all the remnants or you'll end up with
all that dirt on the floor of your car
16 dusting and vacuuming this trick is
ideal because not only does it make your
car cleaner but you save time in the end
if you ever notice how much dust your
car collects over time you will know
that dusting is not an optional task if
you want to keep your car clean however
if you simply dust your car the dust
will resettle and you'll completely
waste your time and will still have a
dusty car so the trick is to dust your
car while vacuuming with the dust you're
going to need a small brush and a vacuum
dust with one hand and hold the vacuum
close by with the other 15 cleaning
small cracks with flat end screwdriver
even though a toothbrush is a great tool
to use to get into those nooks and
crannies sometimes you need something a
little more heavy-duty to get that
really stubborn dirt out that's where
this trick comes in a flat end
screwdriver with a thin cloth over it
will get all the sticky and seemingly
permanent dirt out the screwdriver is
hard so you can do more scraping than
with a toothbrush you specifically want
to use a flat end screwdriver because
it's just the right shape to get into
those hard-to-reach places this would
not work with an Allen wrench or a
Phillips head the cloth is there so you
don't scratch anything in your car 14
trash can this is perhaps the easiest
tip to follow this tip is different from
most of the others
it's a preventative measure leaving a
trashcan or bag in your car will lessen
your cleaning time later on and don't
pretend you take your garbage with you
each time you leave the car we know
that's not true a trash can is almost
essential unless you're not embarrassed
when your friends get in your car and
you have to throw your old fast food bag
and receipts in the backseat even though
you can just keep an old plastic grocery
bag in your car this doesn't look all
that appealing consider using a reusable
plastic cereal container as a trash can
thirteen wet wipes and napkins we can
all be a little messy sometimes and
doesn't it suck when you accidentally
spill some coffee on the seat or in the
cup holder if you don't have anything to
clean it up with then the coffee will
just make your car sticky and covered in
stains an easy solution to this is to
always make sure you have wet wipes or
napkins in the car you can keep them in
your car's middle console or in the door
the wet wipes are also good to wipe your
hands if they're sticky so you don't get
everything else sticky an easy way to
collect napkins as well if you just ask
for extras next time you're in a drive
through 12 rubbing alcohol to clean
windshield wipers isn't it annoying when
your windshield wipers leave streaks in
addition to being annoying this can also
be dangerous as it can potentially block
the drivers view people tend to ignore
this problem because windshield wipers
can be expensive and maybe they don't
have time to go to the store but
eventually those gross streaks across
your windshield will drive you crazy
enough to make you want to fix it q
rubbing alcohol rubbing alcohol is an
easy and affordable way to clean your
wipers wipe down your wipers with a
generous amounts of rubbing alcohol and
let it dry
even though changing your wipers is
still necessary this can lengthen your
wipers lifespan and will help you if
you're in a pinch 11 clean floor mats
with laundry stain remover turns out
stain remover for your clothes isn't
just good to get your Nonna's famous
pasta sauce out of your shirt they can
also be used to clean the floor mats of
your car all you have to do is spray the
mats with stain remover throw them in
the washer with launch detergent and lay
them out to dry you might want to let
the mat sit for a while with the stain
remover depending on the state of them
this is surprisingly so
see and it will save you some
embarrassment when your friends or
family come into your car in the end
these tips are all about saving you from
embarrassment you don't need to be a
slob to have a messy car and you don't
need to spend hundreds of dollars
cleaning your car up ten dryer sheets to
remove bugs bugs will inevitably get
squished on your windshield and in the
grille of your car this can drive you
crazy if you're constantly staring at
the spots while you're driving you'll
also be driven crazy once you get out of
your car and see the little dots all
over the exterior a great way to remove
bugs from your grille and the windshield
is with dryer sheets bugs can be hard to
get off your car so you'll definitely
want to try this trick first you'll want
to wet your car then get a bucket of
warm water and wipe the dryer sheets in
the warm water
lastly wipe those little bugs away 9
clean car exterior with clay it's crazy
the number of everyday items that can do
such a great job cleaning your car this
one may be one of the most surprising
methods have you ever washed your car
and noticed that it's not as shiny as
you wanted it to be or maybe it doesn't
look like it was just cleaned well
that's probably because you've never
tried this trick you can take a bar of
clay which you can get in a children's
toy store or arts section and your
troubles will be solved after washing
your car as you normally would take a
clay bar and rub along the exterior your
car will shine like crazy you can also
purchase clay that is specifically for
cars but why don't have a little fun at
the toy store to get yours eights water
and squeegee to get rid of animal hair
if you have a pet then you know the
struggle of trying to get your animals
hair out of fabric seats it can be
nearly impossible to get everything well
we have a great solution for you all you
need is a squeegee a spray bottle with
water in it and a vacuum all you gotta
do is spray some water on the seats and
push the squeegee along the seats to
collect the hair we recommend squeegee
in from the back of the seat to the
front so you can easily vacuum up the
clumps afterward 7 magic erasers most of
you are probably familiar with the magic
of the Magic Eraser these erasers can be
so helpful in a variety of situations
but have you ever considered using them
to clean your car places you might want
to consider cleaning with a magic eraser
or your steering wheel dashboard and
stay
on your seats and floor make sure you
wipe gently if you rub too hard you
could potentially damage parts of the
interior and according to the mr. clean
website you can clean your tire rims
with magic erasers to however they do
recommend extra durable magic erasers
for the rims thanks mr. clean for making
our car cleaning jobs easier 6
club soda cup soda is another one of
those miracle products that have saved
us from embarrassment and potentially
expensive fixes for example did you know
club soda works wonders to get red wine
out of fabric well cup soda can also
make your clean car dreams come true if
you have non leather fabric seats then
you probably understand the struggle of
keeping your seats clean even if you are
a neat and tidy person this is still
difficult well lucky for you there's
club soda
if this deign is new Pat the steam dry
first then wet a cloth with club soda
and Pat the stain again if it's an older
stain just use more club soda 5 vinegar
oh the magic of vinegar vinegar can be
used for many different tasks around the
house and car cleaning is one of them do
you want a window washing solution that
will make your windows Sparkle all you
have to do is mix vinegar with a little
dishwashing detergent and wash your
windows with that on a rag if you have
stains in your upholstery make some
shampoo or laundry detergent with the
vinegar and work it well into the fabric
make sure you mix well we wonder how
people figure this out do you think it
was by accident or do you think the
people that discovered this used their
scientific knowledge for coca-cola the
world's most popular soft drink is soon
to be a well-known car cleaning product
if that sounds strange to you that's
probably because it is you would hope
that something so many people around the
world consumed wouldn't be able to be
used as a cleaning product well think
again all those chemicals that are in
your can of coke actually have the power
to remove rust stains from your car's
exterior if you've got some particularly
stubborn rust areas all you have to do
is pour some coke on a steel wool pad
and rub it in a circular motion that
might make you think twice next time
before you drink a can of that bubbly
dark liquid 3 frequency of cleaning now
you might think this tip is a little
dull but trust us this is one of the
most important ones and that is to just
make sure you clean your car frequently
and
don't mean every day or every week but
you might want to set aside some time
each month to give your car a little
extra TLC not only will clean your car
regularly and frequently help with your
car's longevity but you'll also spend a
lot less time cleaning your car overall
think about it you could spend one or
two hours a month cleaning your car or
realize two or three months down the
road that your car is disgusting and you
need to spend five hours cleaning it or
you decide to cough up the cash and get
it cleaned professionally so trust us
cleaning your car often will save you
time and money to full noodle if you
park your car in your garage this trick
may be just what you're looking for when
you park your car in the garage it's
possible that you might open your door
and hit it against the garage wall this
could result in unsightly scratches or
dents and this is just not pleasant what
you can do is attach a pool noodle to
the wall where your door would hit the
wall so if you do accidentally open your
door to why the pool noodle will prevent
anything from happening to your door
take your pool noodles cut it in half
lengthwise and either bolts glue or nail
the noodle to the wall one slime this
might be the strangest trick you'll hear
today did you ever play with the ball of
goo or slime when you were younger
children would mold bounce or squish
this weird substance however as soon as
you got any dirt on it your slime would
never be clean again which is probably
why people thought to use slime as a car
cleaner just take some slime and dab it
around your car where dust and dirt
collect easy as that you can buy slime
from kids toy stores but you can also
make your own if you google DIY cleaning
slime you'll get a number of recipes for
how to make your own slime did we miss
any of your go-to car cleaning tips let
us know in the comments below and that's
it for the twenty cleaning tricks Car
Dealers don't want you to know if you
want to see more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 simple life hacks that
could save you a lot of trouble your
life will be so much easier after
watching both these videos
[Music]